ce jeune collégien que vous voyez à côté
de moi ne fais pas de concours de chant
comme daniel rouhier non non pas du tout
c'est le chroniqueur bien connue d'un
journal non moins connu est considérée
ajouterais-je il s'appelle philippe
bouvard est alors la première fois où je
les ai vu je me suis dit qu'on laissait
vraiment les enfants sortir très tard le
soir
alors maintenant j'ai des renseignements
plus ample je sais qu'il est majeur même
un peu plus je sais qu'il est marié qui
l'a même il a même un enfant
parfaitement et et vire je sais
également que beaucoup de gens craignent
sa plume satirique
il a un côté affreuse jour savez qui
vous met du poil à gratter dans le dos
il est mâtiné d'un peu de vieux bon
chinois c'est un personnage très curieux
bon sur ce je les fais venir ce soir
parce que il a une manie une manie il a
la manie des ressemblances plus
exactement le dada des sosies oui mais
je ne voudrais pas qu'on aille penser
qu'il s'agit là seulement d'une des
formations pour un maniaque
oui c'est pas exactement ça voyez vous
la réalité quand même plus complexes
étant appelées professionnellement à
fréquenter sans cesse des célébrités et
des célébrités diverses
j'en suis arrivé très souvent à
m'interroger sur les raisons de cette
célébrité et dans la mesure où mes
questions restaient sans réponse
j'ai pensé qu il la devait d'abord
surtout à l'or physique à ce qu'on nomme
vous savez le physique de l'emploi et
poussant plus loin mon raisonnement
j'ai tenté de trouver des sosies à ces
célébrités et je me suis dit puisque l
on est là aussi le physique de l'emploi
puisque ces saisies ont toutes les
caractéristiques physiques des
célébrités comment ça se fait qu'ils
n'ont pas tenté et réussi une carrière
parallèle
oui c'est assez compliqué vous n'allez
pas d'ailleurs je vais vous donner si
vous le voulez il ya des exemples
l'obtention du baccalauréat utilisation
intensive dans la seconde
ça n'est pas à expliquer tout alors mon
premier exemple vont prendre des saisies
et charmant il annonce qu est de dire oh
james et je peux bien le dire ce n'est
pas indiscret puisque nous venons d'en
d'en convenir
voici quelques instants vous faites du
music-hall bon mais ce que vous n'avez
jamais tenté une carrière
cinématographique
c'est à dire j'ai eu plaisir de doubler
gina lollobrigida il ya deux ans à rome
ah vous êtes donc ce qu'on pourrait
nommer sans aucune exception que je rate
il un sosie utilitaires
le second exemple second sosie c'est
monsieur andré gerald monsieur andré
girel qu'est ce que vous faites
je suis journaliste à nous sommes donc
confrères je m'empresse tout de suite de
préciser que monsieur andré chérel est
un sosie particulier un sosie cyclique
un sosie caméléon j'entends par là que
vers l'âge de 17 ans le confondait avec
andry brûlé jeunes jeu vers 20 ans il
évoquait plutôt les traits de maurice
thénac qu'à 22 ans
on le prenait pour pitoeff sacha pitoeff
c'est exact et vous le trouvez
actuellement dans sa période mais le
ferret monsieur gérald peut-on vous
demander si vous avez des projets pour
les semaines à venir
mais vous pensez bien qu'on ne peut pas
se limiter à l'aube d'une étude aussi
complexe à deux exemples seulement à
deux sosies
c'est là que vous intervenez c'est là
que vous demandons de nous aider voici
michel arnaud et moi même nous avons
pensé vous demander de participer à un
grand concours à un concours de sosies
vous l'avez déjà deviné c'est très
simple vous avez certainement dans votre
entourage proche dans votre entourage
lointain des gens qui ressemblent à des
personnalités célèbres du monde des arts
de la politique du sport que sais-je
bref vous avez sûrement fréquenter une
fausse sophia loren info wiston
churchill est bien ce que vous demandons
c'est encore plus simple c'est de nous
les indiqué avec photos à l'appui pour
que nous puissions juger sur pièce c'est
de nous adresser 3 photo du sosie deux
photos de profil et une photo de face
avec si possible une courte biographie
de nous les adresser et la j'insiste
bien avant lui joue
pour à la télévision française chez vous
ce soir le physique de l'emploi
télévision française 15 rue cognacq-jay
et alors là nous vous réservons une
petite surprise parce que la télévision
française va prendre en charge le ou les
gagnants
parce que nous allons les faire venir à
paris et leur donner la possibilité de
tourner un petit bout drôle dans un
petit film où ils pourront tenir
exactement l'emploi de la célébrité à
laquelle il ressemble tant j'insiste que
sur le côté sérieux de ce concours
si si si si si si j'insiste beaucoup
c'est très sérieux
c'est sans doute peut-être la seconde
chance que nous apportons la le marchand
de célébrités va passer encore une fois
alors je vous en supplie envoyez nous
vos trois photos je connais des
carrières brillantes qui ont débuté avec
beaucoup moins que ça